I love to cook but sometimes you just
want to keep it quick and easy like this
one pot lemon garlic shrimp pasta we'll
cook our pasta and then drain it and set
it aside while we heat up some olive oil
and butter I try to go healthier with
this recipe and use whole grain pasta
but I do end up using an entire stick of
butter please don't judge me once our
spices are slightly toasted We'll add in
our shrimp with some pepper and salt
cook those until they're pink and then
add in spinach once that's wilted We'll
add back in our pasta a little parmesan
and of course we got to have that butter
and squeeze a whole lemon over it and
finally a tiny bit of parsley we'll mix
that all together and we are finished it
was that easy now all that's left to do
is see how it tastes
cheers
M it's too spicy for you too spicy I'll
make you a different version